just tell me something about abby road
for one second i had heard that abbey
road was not supposed to be called abbey
road you were going to call it something
like mount everest or something where
this is true that is true yeah what is
the story there well you know um
you're making an album and
towards the end of the album you start
thinking well we need a title for this
so you're looking around you're fishing
around and the engineer jeff emerick who
is our our beetle engineer did all the
great sounds for us was smoking
cigarettes called everest they're like a
kind of menthol right cigarette at the
time
and we kind of looked at that so everest
it's kind of you know it's big it's
heroic that could be good for the album
and just one day we were in abbey road
working
and
i just sort of said well look you know
why not abbey road because if we did
that we could just run outside right
there's a there's a level crossing as we
call it out there zebra crossing and we
could just stand there we could get
photographed come back to work it'd take
two seconds right i said and it's not a
bad title you know abby wrote to us it
was kind of just the name of a studio
but i thought if you take it out of
context kind of sounds like monastery
lane
abbey road
isn't it weird how just a simple thought
like that becomes a legend i mean that's
like iconic now abby road yeah and yet
it could have been called everest and
that would require the beatles to fly to
mount everest
so in a way it was sort of a lazy
approach it was a cheap approach it was
a cheap approach